. Let's get right into audience questions,
first one today.
David, I've heard you say that the stock market
does better with Democratic presidents than
Republican.
Does the country always do better when there
is a Democratic president economically?
So we have to know what metrics we're looking
at when we try to measure how the country
is doing.
There are a number of different indicators
that we would look at.
No one indicator tells us everything we need
to know.
We would look at GDP growth, unemployment
and stock market performance.
Certainly as indicators, we would probably
take a look at what portion of the country
is poor below the poverty line.
What's the degree of inequality?
There are other metrics that can be a little
squishier because they relate to others.
So we could say, well, how how strong is the
dollar?
But that would be related to our trade deficit
or surplus.
And it's harder to say we're doing well or
we're not without kind of a more systemic
approach.
And then you've got intangibles, right?
Like how respected are we around the world
right now?
Respect for the United States is very, very
low because of Donald Trump.
How do you sort of price that into the equation?
But to pick a few of these indicators, yes,
the stock market does better under Democratic
presidents than Republicans.
A lot of people don't care about the stock
market.
The stock market is not the economy, as we
have very clearly seen during the last three
months of corona virus.
But the return, the annualized return during
Democratic administrations has been fourteen
point three percent, whereas it has been ten
point eight percent under Republicans.
So, yes, the stock market does better under
Democrats in terms of GDP growth.
GDP growth is significantly higher under Democratic
presidents than Republican presidents.
Typically, it depends on exactly how you measure
and the uncertain timing issues.
But it's anywhere from 15 to 44 percent larger
GDP growth during Democratic presidential
administrations than Republican in terms of
unemployment.
Unemployment tends to be higher during Republican
administrations, 18 percent higher by one
study that I looked at in terms of job creation.
Remember jobs created and the unemployment
rate or do two different things.
Since World War Two, Democratic presidents
have seen more than twenty four point four
million more jobs created during their watch.
That's an average of 78 percent more jobs
created per year of Democratic administrations
versus Republican administrations.
So, yeah, by those indicators, we do better
with Democratic presidents.
Now, the thing is, somebody believes Republicans
are just better for the economy.
These data won't convince them.
They'll say, well, some of that is because
of lag time.
You see better metrics when a Democrat takes
over because of the policies the Republicans
put in place.
This has been pretty widely debunked, but
still people continue to repeat it.
You will sometimes hear, well, Democrats
spend in order to make some of these metrics
look better.
Well, it's like if you trust the metrics and
government spending improves the metrics,
then that's good, right?
I mean, they were the right will try to argue
that these are sort of like cheap ways to,
quote, improve the economy, which sounds crazy.
I mean, it literally sounds crazy.
Other metrics like poverty.
I mean, the thing about poverty is if I change
the poverty level, if I say, well, instead
of being poor at fifteen thousand dollars
a year, you're only poor below twelve.
I've just taken millions of people out of
poverty.
I've not really changed anything.
So that's why poverty is not really the best
metric.
Inequality is important, but as always, you
know, mean median mode.
Looking at something like the Guinea Index
JNI, there's different ways to look at that.
But in short, yeah, I mean, the traditional
indicators that we look at suggest that the
economy does better when we have a Democratic
president than a Republican president since
the early nineteen hundreds, when we have,
you know, more or less or really even the
World War two era, we would say when things
are sort of measured in the same way.
And you can always mean
the reason I'm sort of hesitating is that
this question is inherently fraught because
any empirical differences you can point to
can be explained away by motivated reasoning.
And so it's a fair question, but it's a really
difficult one to convince anybody about in
a way that would materially change their perspectives.
On what?
The right policies are.